in magnus's hands it often does get uh
very very interesting and quite sharp I
people I think used to just autopilot
Bishop G3 in these types of positions
and then
I think people realized you can leave it
on F4
and there was I think of at a certain
point there was a lot of discussion of
this specific structure like I don't
know 9 bd2 which before
uh EF and then eventually White
like some kind of a structure like this
right I will bangle the move order
horribly but I think there was a bunch
of high level games starting from these
types of positions I think Magnus had it
against Vichy in one of the world rapid
and blitzes
he got it against carwana once as well
from another move order uh he's
definitely the champion of this Pawn
structure for white
so today he does something else he gives
a check on B5 takes on C6 takes on D6
and queen A4 where
um I guess Queen A3 is a kind of an
annoying little idea but he doesn't
actually do it immediately after castles
looks like like Queen A3 is playable but
he just castles himself allowing black
seemingly to sort of escape the cage a
little bit with CD4 CD4 C5
Rook C1
yeah what was Black's answer to Queen A3
either earlier or here I don't really uh
see it I've played campski a few times
online and he always plays this kind of
queen A3 trick against 94 and we've
reestablished the idea of index D4 right
um I suppose yeah because like Knight
bg2 we just go CD4 and it looks like we
don't lose material yeah
C1 this is an interesting strategic
turning point because
um
C4 is what ding chose and it's I mean
perfectly playable of course but
I'm also
not sure how I feel about this structure
like if this was a bishop which is on D6
I think you pick black every single time
right but because the bishop is on C8
and it's going to be very difficult to
find good squares for it yeah it feels
like the White Knight is very far from
C5 though
um
this is why this is why I wasn't sure
exactly exactly the point that you're
bringing up is that E5 is a nice square
but E5 we can move the Knight away from
F6 and play of seven or six ourselves So
eventually we should hope to be able to
smoke it out
uh and C5 would be in like uh a
permanent Square for the night but
getting the Knight there will take a
long long time
but they both I guess agreed that white
is at least a little bit better here
because Jing I mean Magnus was inviting
this and ding didn't go for it keep
blade C4 B3 Bishop D7 Queen A5 takes
takes and now Rook fb8 9 bg2 and Rook B5
came in I do wonder whether keeping the
Queens on I'm not sure Queen C3 or queen
A2
um what black does over the next few
moves I mean you can put up on an A5
sure but 95 is still coming maybe White
just keeps the tension for as long as
possible yeah kind of reroute the
knights around to C5 before just
deciding whether to trade off those
Queens this is sadly a bit of a
non-event like we were very I think at
least I was very much looking forward to
this game but Zing just defended really
really well today uh so we we saw this
and in this position among the spent
95-b893 which is very logical but ding
found a way to uh just prepare and play
for very very quickly
which day five rugby seven or K7 using
the fact that white I mean has a very
beautiful Square on C5 but not very much
else
and now a very clean move Knight C8
unpinning the uh A4 Pawn
and uh yeah
white is
I guess has a slightly better light
pieces but you're not really
pressing too hard here uh in a in a very
symmetrical five against five with no
Witnesses
how much longer do you think he'll play
on Peter
not not very long not very long not very
long yeah maybe we should stay here then
uh yeah just until they shake hands
until it's confirmed yeah black can play
pretty much anything just nicely after
tape take I don't know honestly I don't
even I don't even think to lose if you
play G6 but you'll never played G6
Knight C7 F6 is just much much yeah much
more definitely correct yeah I mean
white actually created one thread here
which needs to be addressed but once
you've addressed it
there's really not very much else to
discuss yeah as you say as well G6 you
probably get away with it that's black
you've probably just yeah still still
hold but yeah well of course you play
nice yourself
you play 97 I know you want to play six
and
as long as you don't completely abandon
control over the dark squares you
uh you you never lose yeah Magnus goes
Knight H5 and I guess after Knight H5
you can just play King of fate and now
F6 is a threat so you're gonna have to
fall back King E7 and you even find a
very cute threefold to to to not have to
actually actually on that note is there
a rule Peter no I think I think they're
free to do what they please are like in
general at least in in yesteryear uh in
the in the days of your you could do
whatever you pleased but yeah yeah okay
king of Fate played yeah uh you've
played vike many times I guess I played
I think five or six yeah okay what kind
of results uh what experience I was once
on plus three with two rounds to go okay
I will give you one guess as to how many
points I had by the end of this round I
won't ask
we will win
uh yeah I
um it was kind of tragic because that
was the only year where I was actually I
think I thought I was playing well and I
was doing quite well and then
I got mated in like 25 moves by Lucky in
some grunfield
I okay I think I've seen that game
actually yeah
and then uh or maybe in the other the
other way around and I also got out
prepared in some very very sharp night
or by the youngster get correct
we got mated as well with white pieces
so yeah
did not end well yeah lots of well
everyone's strong in bike that's the
problem
yeah and yeah I think we'll see that
handshake any second now very very close
yeah repetition moves and I'm surprised
Magnus didn't take on uh doing in some
main lines just to at least ask the
question how much ding is willing to
reveal but
um yeah it looks like a decent antidote
to the London system well unless you
actually you know some years ago I would
feel like I'm joking here like you know
very droll haha but
you know for London does feel like it's
a bit of a main line for Magnus as well
like it's I think he plays it very
seriously it's not like it's a it's a
give up it's uh
no true and there we do see the
handshake it is a draw